Rick Harrison teases the upcoming
bachelor season with Ben Higgins he's
just a good man and very sincere and
humble but he's a little vulnerable
little fragile and you know we get back
to Kaitlyn's season when he talked about
being unlovable and we obviously deal
with that and you'll see that kind of
play out throughout the season and when
you set the bar so high with a guy like
that obviously there's something to
fight for and the women are fighting for
him
what kind of fights can we expect this
season you brought it up good dramatic
but here's the thing it's it's not about
like who's bad who's evil whatever this
season is just about he's a catch I mean
they see this guy is a massive catch of
all the people I would say Ben reminds
me of it's Sean Lowe just as far as the
sincerity and sweet and humble and and
the guys that you kind of you got a
glimpse of Sean back on Emily's season
but you really fell in love with him
when you got to know him on The Bachelor
same thing with Ben you got a taste of
him on Kaitlyn's season but once America
really sees who he is they're gonna
freak out and so I think it's funny I
think his season is you would most
resemble Sean's what about the twins
because there were no twins on Sean's
season they make it to hometown date
like well how does that work
maybe in a way they do you'll see oh and
remember Becca Tilly from Chris soules a
season I don't think I'm the guy that's
gonna be able to give you a name Becca
all but confirmed
she'll be back this season for a chance
at that
how do you think he might be worth the
risk before I go okay so maybe we can't
expect a little vodka osteon